[Music]
this week we've got sausage suitcase hmm
strange copyright and fat shaming Karma
oh hi skinny shame or fitness shame or
just shame or shame
I think shaming people is good I don't
know I like shaming the [ __ ] out of you
guys remember this shame shame shame
what does that mean what is shaming
people again first story there's this
man that is being allowed back to a
hotel after 17 years of having a ban for
an incident that involved suitcases in a
suitcase full of a brownie and a flock
of very hungry stables and an open
window [ __ ] it's like Hangover Part 3
this is [ __ ] funny and I wish I could
read to you the whole Facebook post was
too long to read so I'll just paraphrase
so he's the one that caused obesity
promise evils the pepperoni ass
suitcases yeah it takes place in Nova
Scotia in Canada I've ever been there
back in 2001 Nick he was visiting the
Fairmont Empress Hotel in Victoria and
he was gonna meet up with some of his
friends from the Navy so he brought a
suitcase full of pepperoni cuz they
loved this particular pepperoni oh [ __ ]
it's basically I just see a [ __ ]
Pizza Hut commercial with the pepperoni
just slowly all this and it's like yes
y'all got a mountain Mike's out here no
what is that
mom ice is like a I guess is I thought
it was a chain that's all over the place
but it's a pizza joint but they're
they're pepperoni has like so much fat
into it then when they cook the the
pepperoni pizza it turns into a cup and
then it's just like a pull of pepperoni
or it looks almost like a sausage yeah
she's [ __ ] I like the mom-and-pop
ones when you take out the [ __ ] pizza
slice and it looks like
all this cheese is trying to stay on top
and [ __ ] pulling back at it like it's
like doing cheese total war and [ __ ]
like I like that too oh yeah what
happened so this hotel at that time
didn't have a refrigerator or AC and so
he decided to keep the pepperoni cool by
laying it all out by this window this
big window amazing so he left the window
a little cracked open and it was like
you know chili Canadian air
so that was keeping the pepperoni cool
then he went out for a walk for about
four or five hours
who the [ __ ] walks that long that's a
long walk that's like a job we don't
know how they do it at Canada all right
okay Canada it's a waste of time that's
what that is
hey guys I'm gonna go out for a stroll
or five hours I'll be back tomorrow guys
well you know is it pepperoni like a
cured meat anyway it is yeah so why the
[ __ ] do you use them okay yeah so then
by the time he went back into his room
he saw about 40 seagulls in there inside
inside his room going ham that was the
only pepperoni yeah I went in through
the crack the window like he left open
and then he says pepperoni does nasty
things to a seagulls digestive system so
there was both the entire room was
covered in seagull crap oh he said he's
like I didn't realize this but seagulls
also drools
so it was like they drool everywhere
they blamed him for that and banned him
from the hotel oh no it gets better
yes I didn't know seagulls like imported
the pepperoni backs so he took all the
seagulls and he cooked them no grab the
seagull [ __ ] took the pepperoni on it
eat it like that Chinese baby no so in
this dude walked into the room all the
birds started freaking out and flying
everywhere with crap and drool
everywhere and crashing into things and
so in the he says in the tornado of
seagull excrement feathers pepperoni
tongues and fairly large birds whipping
around the room that's when he decided
to grab a towel to like get this one
particular bird and I'm he hexa dentling
like the bird fell out of the window and
he didn't realize like the bird can't
really fly so she fell out of the window
luckily though no birds got injured so
then most of these first started getting
out of the window and
in that whole commotion he grabbed this
shoe he threw it at one of the birds and
they fell out of the window and then I'm
hitting someone
this guy's not very proud why is it Dora
shoes a seagull's he's problematic this
is a [ __ ] slapstick movie yeah yeah
yeah where you just keep like it's like
Ace Ventura this is like some yeah it's
like a Jim Carrey movie from the 90s
dude or Dumb and Dumber oh the poo poo
scene yeah Oh true Burnie this is the
first company trip with his brand-new
company that he's he's joined almost
just like he could not miss this very
important dinner and he was just like
panicking so he realized I can't leave
without just with just one shoe so he
went to go get his shoe outside and he
was like all right this whole mess in
the room I'll deal with it later I have
to go to my dinner sing ended up going
and then when he got back to the room he
saw like the lady the housekeeping lady
just like her face was just like what
the [ __ ] like this room is insane
I'd be like that she was just like she's
like I'm so he was like I'm so sorry so
he got his shoe he tried cleaning it
there was one shoe was wet the other one
was dry but I'm just wetting the dry one
and just moving on he decided to
blow-dry the wet one and by doing that
he ended up causing the whole power to
go out he's very problematic so the ends
that are banning this guy and so he
ended up posting this whole letter on
Facebook telling the Empress Hotel like
you know I'm sorry like with my hat on
my in my hands like I apologize I've
I've served all this time like you know
please would you allow me to stay in
your hotel like why would he want to go
back to the same hotel there's so many
options right I don't know I honestly
feel like this dude was he was just
trying to like tell this very hilarious
story and the hotel it seemed to seem to
agree with him though cuz they were like
oh yeah we've lifted the ban so there
was a real band but it just sounds so
fake and outlandish especially when you
read the way he writes it is just so
descriptive
like one of those guys that's always
complaining the world is against him but
he's the one that's causing all the
farms yeah well he has a really great
sense of humor this this post went viral
is he young his young guy this is the
photo light he posted with it anyone
that has a suitcase full of pepperonis
is it has it good oh this guy well this
is the photo that was attached to his
letter his open letter and then like the
people from the hotel are just crappy
they're laughing cuz eating that [ __ ] is
hilarious and unreal and they lifted the
ban does not under Chinese management
they don't care it's a five-star hotel
oh [ __ ] yeah a five-star hotel with no
air-conditioning
I didn't even think about macaroni
slices or was it the pepperoni use their
beats to go through the paper oh yeah
and you eat a seagull yeah I guess you
could eat anything
I mean people eat squirrels they eat
pigeons yeah I don't know but I really
recommend you guys reading his post cuz
I really like the way you wrote it and I
feel like I didn't do the story justice
probably didn't very like he's a good
storyteller I think he is I just
pictured the stupidest man on earth
that's what I picture yeah that's some
[ __ ] Panther it seems like very pinky up
there to me he sounds like someone that
were their socks inside I'll fall
downstairs
David's very accident alright someone
that would like not leave their
shoelaces tied and the play basketball
really hard and twist her ankles snap
all the tendons so much I'm like that
but David is like one accident at a time
no he's not in the same thing no no but
then this is within the same room yeah
and after the after what it's like that
yeah I know someone that's like that I'm
just one after the other at a time I am
one at a time accidents yes he's one at
a time he's not like one after the other
then sometimes it's things that are even
out of his control like the boat thing
where we were on this boat
camera out and then no the captain on
that boat whatever he was like oh yeah
we never get any water on the boat ever
don't worry about it he's recording and
the next thing you know this huge ass
wave covers that it only hits him
no it hit us all he hit us all dude it
hit our cameras you guys any of cameras
out well I didn't we're vlogging though
oh yeah it also took out my cell phone
nope nothing worked
but it only hid his camera equipment
when someone to other people that got
hit with water the worst look on earth
alright next story
did you guys hear that the duffer
brothers are being sued for stealing the
idea of stranger things what the [ __ ] is
duffer brothers the strange that these
creators idea from apparently was from
this other filmmaker that he presented
this short film at the Hamptons
International Film Festival back in 2012
they actually won an award there but he
approached the duffer brothers directly
telling them about this particular story
which is called
the Montauk Project and it's similar
where it's like government experiments
and then like using orphans we're not
our friends but like Runaways to do
these types of experiments and now he's
saying like they just straight up stole
his idea and that originally when they
were pitching stranger things to Studios
that they were using the same name to
that's what he claims so are they gonna
be in trouble are they going to live at
gas stations there's a lawsuit going on
cuz I feel like you have a paper trail
of that right there has to be something
where you're like you emailed them an
idea and it was very similar yeah I'm
saying I mean he must have some sort of
case abuse because that's what happened
with the what's it called the which
matrix oh yeah yeah and then the in the
matrix happen with the matrix yeah so
the matrix if you notice like the the
first matrix was the only good one right
and so there was a writer that that
created that script right and it wasn't
it's supposed to be a two and three yeah
so but you know without that person the
two and the two and three were compassed
Lee different from the first one mm-hmm
and so like forth at MIT so you got
settled out or something like that and
like in there saying like we didn't
steal it but the evidence shows from a
filmmakers but I guess you see it they
say number one is song
two and three sucks ass yeah it's like I
wonder [ __ ] why dude you know what I
mean so I'm a thousand percent sure they
stole that [ __ ] and then they couldn't
create two and three that great because
it was such hot garbage
it definitely drove it didn't even
really like correlate that well to the
first one people make that sequel
argument but like check out JK Rowling
[ __ ] that's just good all the way yeah
oh this dude is he's a producer name's
Charlie Kessler he's he's the one that's
suing the brothers but the brothers
attorney said this mister kessler's
claim is completely meritless he had no
connection to the creation or
development of stranger things
the duffer brothers have neither seen
mr. Kessler short film nor discussed any
project with him this is just an attempt
to profit from other people's creativity
and hard work that could be true to now
who knows
cuz when you're talking to people like
you just you know you riff and like
ideas come out and then they come up
with something sand learn and you're
like excuse me that was my idea
yeah I just say idea don't need [ __ ]
execution is everything because they
might have heard it they might have been
like oh yeah that's the pitch oh that's
cool and then they go into a Ryder
circle and they're like oh [ __ ] you know
what I have this idea and they forgot
where that inspiration came from they
think they came up with it yeah and then
they develop it unless they just got the
whole script okay that's strange news
cuz like if they already had the short
film or whatever made in 2012 the script
was already laid out and it's like
identical to it that's just beyond like
chance yes like it's way beyond just
happens to it's not it's not possible
people do that on YouTube
[Music]
piece of [ __ ] yep they steal steal steal
steal steal alright for a last story
there's this team that posted on
Facebook
something very petty that she did so her
name she's 19 years old from Indiana her
name is Becca this is a [ __ ] looks like
Vega Vega hello Vega I thought it was a
girl on the left with a beard
yeah so she posted this on Facebook
tonight I was really petty so I saw on
Facebook that a local bakery was having
a sale on everything before they closed
tonight so I headed over there there was
a lady in front of me getting a cake and
a lady behind me with her friends as I
was waiting in line the lady in the
front of me took forever getting her
cake and the lady behind me it was
really was being really impatient and
rude be talking about it I ignored it
until the lady in front of me left and
as I walked up to the counter the lady
turns to her friend and says thank God
now let's hope this fat [ __ ] doesn't
buy all the cupcakes originally I was
gonna buy six but as soon as I heard
that I bought every damn cupcake
I spent $54 on cupcakes just to be a
[ __ ] happy Easter we managed by here's
news friends I suppose that's [ __ ]
hilarious type that's dope great oh
that's dope I like that I'm petty I will
do it
complete fall down he's got a dick on a
cupcake no it's like that swirl from the
host no above that oh there yeah looks
like a hard ass dildo on top of the
cupcake I think it's a steamer or
something you know what that reminds me
of how are dicks
the hostess cupcake they do the swirl
like that - what are you have my white
Oh ding dongs ding dongs that's being
[ __ ] dogs man would you do something
like that yeah but then a cupcake what a
swirl [ __ ] yeah dude you know I like
baking I think yeah I would have some
dude you're gonna be like I can [ __ ]
hear you I'm with an ear shucking fat
but I spoke to here you [ __ ] ugly
[ __ ] so now you get no cupcakes then
buying every [ __ ] cupcake in yeah I
would have been like what's your least
favorite cupcake lemon okay I'll buy
everything except for the lemon cream
and cookies but then what if she's like
ooh my favorite lemon joke's on you fat
[ __ ] mmm that's true I gotta buy all of
it yeah yeah the whole store yes you did
the right thing
that's pretty awesome though I mean
that's the best way to get back at them
I don't really have a sweet tooth so I
probably wouldn't have done that like it
was like Porto's then maybe do you buy
the entire stock of depending on how
much it costs if it was like a thousand
dollars every like I'll get you back
next time
you know but it's like likely a couple
hundred bucks and I'll do it you
than anything cafe is it no but like
it's crazy how how nice someone is
determines the outcome like I've been in
a situation where we're in line for like
donuts are like portals or something
like that and then like I overhear
someone go oh man I hope no one buys
like everything another there's there
are four like go out with pastries left
I'll just buy two and mahek have the
other two you know because when the way
you hear their tone of voice it sound
like they really want it yeah and
they've been really hopeful this down in
line waiting all day that could have
been a waiter for outcomes she's like
all hope no one buys all the cupcakes in
sectionally I hope that fat [ __ ] don't
buy all the cupcakes yeah that was penny
the outcome is that happens in life if
somebody's behind me they're like do to
help you simple like guava Creek plate
with it whatever [ __ ] and I know there's
only four and I was gonna get four I'm
like [ __ ] sucks for you dude I think
sure I get all of it I'm like I've been
the happiest moon of my life do you
think if they directly asked you like
hey would you mind not getting them all
would you still buy them I'll buy oh do
I had no idea but that you believe you
know that I would have been like sorry
man I promised my guys back out work I'd
get this you know my guys in the guava
pastry well with your petty thing that
you did
so yesterday it's really small but it's
super petty so yesterday um I was
driving and then you go to the stop sign
right and then at the stop sign you
either go on the left hand side to
continue straight or if you go on the
right hand side it pushes you out and
you have to make a right so I was
probably like five cars were ahead of me
and this this this little car he comes
and instead of waiting behind everyone
he like cuts us off right and I'm like
oh this [ __ ] sucks like because it's
a known stop that like you got a veer to
the left to go straight on like that
[ __ ] sucks burns a [ __ ] [ __ ] so
somehow fate had it that like this
person ended up behind me so I'm like
all right [ __ ] for cutting now
you're gonna actually wait your [ __ ]
turn so I was driving like 25 miles or
less
I was so slow and I'm like
now you gotta like [ __ ] be patient
that's my bit you showed them I did I
don't care
it felt good in my heart but then I was
fighting myself I'm like this is such a
waste of your [ __ ] time if I'm like
they got a show on because what if they
were just having a conversation in the
car and they were unaware of what they
were doing and then they're just like my
oh no they knew cuz a lot of people were
honking oh they knew they're being a
dick okay they did it anyway they did it
anything they're being a dick yeah
finally made them look so nice he's like
oh she always give people benefit though
I always immediately go to there being
evil and in there I can't think like
that because if I start getting
irritated over I don't know how to be
like middle ground yeah I'm either
yelling at them and like [ __ ]
swerving and trying to crash into them
or I'm just like let it go let it I
don't know how to begin road rage I
don't even ha I get life rage like I I
really try to come from like be an adult
and be like okay it's always about
intentions what is somebody's intention
behind their because then I'm not to get
personally yeah let it go I will go
[ __ ] apeshit like I off on people
like I I go off on people very Prius boy
by the airport try to use a Prius boy
and I'm just having fun we're all we're
all trying to fly to Hawaii and [ __ ] and
I roll down the window and I called him
out to fight any [ __ ] drove off yeah
I was screaming in his face and I was
like don't raise your voice at people
and have road rage if you're not ready
to fight see I have road rage but I
don't directed at people because it's
not worth it's like why do you feel it
now so it's just like you [ __ ]
[ __ ] son of a [ __ ] I do that
sometime but if they roll down the
window excuse me I'm like good evening
like that like the taxi driver yesterday
that cut you off just to just like a
second faster yeah they weren't even
using the left turn light side but they
just had to get out and get back in like
that [ __ ] and I was like wow oh I just
say it in the gorgeous not let it go
[ __ ] [ __ ] then that's fine yeah
but it's so hard like even that
confrontation like if I heard someone
talking [ __ ] like oh I hope this
but who doesn't do this and that like I
wouldn't know what to do I would just be
like either confront him face-to-face or
just let it go I don't know what else
yeah I can't be that middle ground
person mariel almost broke up with me
once because it was the first time she
ever saw me angry and this is like in
the first year that we were dating and
we were going to LACMA and an awesome
like I was on the phone with my mom
what Bluetooth that like this but it was
having a good time and then basically
this dude like in this [ __ ] thing's
got badly or some [ __ ] right and so
you know like when the when the lanes
[ __ ] merchant [ __ ] the guy almost
like pulls me off the road and I'm just
going just give Mike a quick finger like
[ __ ] [ __ ] and it continued right
but he almost threw me off the [ __ ]
Road so I had a swarm out and I'm most
at the divider so I was like what the
[ __ ] and it's like whatever it is moved
on but you like you grazes over the
[ __ ] you know just you know a little
quick little thing it wasn't even me
yelling I was still talking to my mom on
the phone so it's more like whatever
dude and then we just kind of continue
big-eyed like like he took that and then
the guy just starts like blaring is horn
B and I'm like so distracted talking to
my mom you know we're just having a good
time I'm like oh yeah me so cool and so
we're driving him the guy like rolls up
and then he told me to pull down the
window and then Mario's sitting next
mission site don't like don't roll down
your window I don't know what's going on
so I just roll down the window on myut a
directions oh [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] you up
and I literally went from son of a
[ __ ] the guy was like whoa so
literally I ended up chasing the dude
Wow
Merida was like hella scared and I was
just like [ __ ] livid you know what I
mean but he asked me to pull over and he
wouldn't pull over my pants this was the
problem and so and he ended up losing me
because he likes plop into another
freeway cuz you can't [ __ ] with crazy
yeah and then I [ __ ] well he's what
happened to me yeah he started yelling
at me you know I [ __ ] tried you cut
me off you [ __ ] this [ __ ] dad I'm all
like you wanna [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Laughter]
and then he just stopped and he backed
up around me he did a [ __ ] behind and
he drove off do you want behind you he
went behind you [ __ ] what I forgot my
mom was on Bluetooth and then it was
just dead quiet in the car and I was
like seething right and all I heard it
my mom is william create well if it's in
English she goes David wait why did she
say did Korean baby she's just bullying
my crib name in Google David alright did
you see her do you rage again started
lecturing me through the but in a very
sweet way she's like it's not very nice
to relax
that's not feeling so terrible and I
just learned I finally noticed that
burial was oh my gosh she was mortified
yeah I mean because she's a very sweet
girl that she doesn't blow up numbers
anything she's calm I think yeah you
know it was just a quick like a quick
one yeah I thought that is what you get
though if you're trying to [ __ ] murder
me yeah Peter I mean so it was like one
of those things were like the guy just
try to you try to speed up and cut
everybody off when clearly he can't
and then everybody alpha to do this yeah
so it's like what the [ __ ] that's why I
always say like don't be aggressive
toward people or just give off negative
energy because you don't know who's
crazy and who could snap on you cuz you
might be like if you know if I'm in line
and if I say oh that [ __ ] fat ass I
hope he doesn't buy all the [ __ ] he
could turn around and pop me in the face
he could come stab me there could be
like a lot of crazies out there so I'm
thinking that people that are like that
they've never got their asses handed to
they never met crazy before that's why
they have a mouth on them or you know
it's like that's why I'm just always
like careful and I'm like yeah let it go
let it go
[Music]